[Musique]
cette année le mois de mai a été le plus
sec depuis 1942 pour la grande région de
montréal
la moyenne des précipitations est de 81
mm il est tombé seulement 12 mm
résultat le niveau de la plupart des
cours d'eau
abc il ya dix excès et securid ce qui
est inhabituel c'est que le succès qu
habituellement ou la période cherche
elle a lieu à la fin de l'été cette
année c'est au début
cette sécheresse a aussi touché le
bassin des grands lacs dont le lac
ontario qui se déverse dans le fleuve
saint laurent
donc le fleuve à l'heure actuelle
devrait être autour on devrait avoir
environ 8000 mètres cubes seconde on est
à 6006 est c'est un petit peu plus beau
mais c'est pas encore problématique en
effet le niveau du fleuve saint-laurent
varie énormément d'une année à l'autre
et c'est normal présentement il est à
4,8 mètres par rapport au niveau de la
mer le record du plus bas niveau a été
atteint en septembre 2012 avec 4,2 m le
débit est contrôlé par le conseil
international du lac ontario et du
fleuve saint-laurent pour assurer le
transport maritime
les armateurs eux s'attendent à voir un
certain niveau dans leur zèle ray
pourquoi parce que si le niveau de sa
plus beau que le niveau usuel alors rue
sont obligés de décharger donc ça leur
bien un coût économique assauts aucun
danger pour l'instant pour les gros
navires commerciaux pour les
plaisanciers
c'est une autre histoire l'arrière du
bateau jack orman sur la plage yves
plante fabrique des voiles avirons au
québec
aujourd'hui il doit effectuer une
opération délicate et déplacé l'un de
ces voiliers plus au large
conséquence directe du très bas niveau
du fleuve saint laurent
normalement on met à langres ici deux
embarcations et l'onu une seule qui ont
de la difficulté à la place et jeu
bordeaux on n'est pas les seuls à avoir
d un sérieux défi nous on s'en tire pas
si mal on peut les déplacer relativement
facilement
mais les autres embarcations plus loans
et où est le problème
simon du planty est capitaine depuis
plus de vingt ans le fleuve n'a plus de
secret pour lui des endroits que
normalement on parle c'est un début de
saison où l'année passée au passé et que
présentement on peut plus passer ce
qu'il craint c'est que le bas niveau de
l'eau pose des accidents il ya un très
gros engouement pour les embarcations
nautiques pour s'assurer que d'être
prudent surtout pour les nouveaux pas
prendre de risque et s'assurer que vous
naviguez en territoire connu leurs 18
ans à sète se laisser distraire par la
beauté de l'océan où la beauté du plan
d'eau et de ne pas regarder sa carte et
de passer tout droit dans des canaux qui
sont balisés puis
puis justement d'aller accrocher la
garde côtière canadienne est aussi
préoccupé par les risques d'accidents
sur les plans d'eau et demande aux
plaisanciers de redoubler de prudence
ici marie michel lauzon radio canada
montréal